so we have f of X equaling 4x to the
fifth minus 3x squared plus 3 all of
that over 6x to the fifth minus 100x
squared minus 10 and what I want to
think about is what is the limit of f of
X as X approaches as X approaches
infinity and there are several ways that
you could do this you could actually try
to plug in larger and larger numbers for
X and see if it seems to be approaching
some value or you could reason through
this and when I talk about reasoning
through this is to think about the
behavior of this numerator and
denominator as X gets very very very
large and what I'm talking about that
what I'm saying is is X gets very very
large let's just focus on the numerator
as X gets very very large this term
right over here in the numerator for X
to the fifth is going to become much
much more significant than any of these
other things
something squaring gets large but
something being raised to the fifth
power gets raised that much much faster
similarly in the denominator this term
right over here the highest degree term
6x to the fifth is going to grow much
much much faster than any of these other
terms even though this has a hundred as
a coefficient or a negative 100 as a
coefficient when you take something to
the fifth power it's going to grow so
much faster than x squared so as X gets
very very very large this thing is going
to approximate for X to the fifth over
over 6x to the fifth over 6x to the
fifth for very large for very large
large X or we could say as X approaches
infinity now what could this be
simplified to well you have X to the
fifth divided by X to the fifth these
are going to grow together so these you
can think of them as cancelling out and
so you are left with two thirds so what
you could say is is the limit of f of X
as X approaches infinity as X gets
larger and larger and larger all of
these other terms aren't going to matter
that much and so it's going to approach
2/3 it's going to approach 2/3 now let's
look at the graph and see if that
actually makes sense what we're actually
saying is that we have a horizontal
asymptote at y is equal to 2/3
look at the graph so right here is the
graph got it from Wolfram Alpha and we
see indeed as X gets larger and larger
and larger f of X seems to be
approaching this value that looks right
at around two-thirds so it looks like we
have a horizontal asymptote right over
here
let me draw that a little bit neater we
have a horizontal asymptote right at
two-thirds so let me draw it as neatly
as I can so this right over here is y is
equal to Y is equal to two-thirds the
limit as X gets really really large as
it approaches infinity y is getting
closer and closer and closer to
two-thirds now when we just look at the
graph here it seems like we haven't it
seems like the same thing is happening
from the bottom direction when X
approaches negative infinity so we could
say the limit of f of X as X approaches
negative infinity that also looks like
it's 2/3 and we can use the exact same
logic when X becomes a very very very
very negative number as it gets if it
becomes further and further to the left
on the number line the only terms that
are going to matter are going to be the
4 X to the 5th and the 6th X to the 5th
so this is true for very large X's it's
also true for very negative X's so we
could also say as X approaches negative
infinity this is also true and then the
X to the fifth over the X to the fifth
is going to cancel out these are the
dominant terms and you were going to be
get and we're going to get it equaling
two-thirds and once again you see that
you see that in the graph here we have a
horizontal asymptote at y is equal to
two-thirds whether we take the limit of
f of X as X approaches infinity we get
2/3 and the limit of f of X as X
approaches negative infinity is 2/3 so
in general whenever you do this you just
have to think about what terms are going
to dominate the rest and focus on those